we've heard a lot about the metaverse in
the past year but is it really going to
be creating new digital economies or is
it just about selling existing
real-world goods
[Music]
every new generation of media has been
subsidized by advertising making it
cheaper or even free for consumers from
newspapers to the radio to tv and indeed
the world wide web there's little reason
to think that the metaverse would be any
different meta platforms that's
facebooked you or me said so explicitly
when it unveiled its vision for the
metaverse last year businesses will be
creators too building out digital spaces
or even digital worlds and they'll be
able to use ads to ensure the right
customers find what they've created so
there we have it for mark zuckerberg and
co the business model for the metaverse
will be the same as it was for social
media
ads pair that with ar and vr's ability
to track your eyeballs and maybe even
gauge your mood and it starts to become
a little creepy but to what extent are
brands taking the metaverse seriously
big names like nike and samsung are
building virtual worlds facebook meta
has teams selling virtual billboards in
those worlds but they remain a
relatively small slice of firm's overall
marketing budgets and you can see why
just 67 million americans will
experience vr content at least once a
month in 2022 and they'll be split
between a range of different platforms
from roblox to minecraft and beyond
facebook alone had
263 million users in the start of this
year in north america crucially though
most of the efforts have so far focused
on selling real world goods nike wants
you to buy actual sneakers samsung real
cell phones the luxury brand burberry
might have made four hundred thousand
dollars selling digital skins with an
associated nft last year but that's
really just a rounding error in its
three billion dollars in annual revenue
in other words they were a marketing
gimmick to attract young crypto
enthusiasts you might hope as a brand
are wealthy meta's ideal is for brands
to pay to advertise virtual goods in the
virtual world that will let it monitor
the entire customer journey from seeing
the ad campaign to buying the product
then even seeing how they use it it
feels like we're a long way away from
that happening just yet if the metaverse
takes off there of course will be big
money to be made in advertising it just
seems we're a long way right now from
that happening and facebook's vision is
a distant prospect